bienvenue dans cette émission spéciale
40 ans de Saint-Quentin en ieline on a
abordé beaucoup de domaines l'économie
les transports la santé la culture et il
y a un domaine qui est très très présent
dans cette communauté de 550 divline
c'est le sport on pourrait même dire que
c'est un des piliers de saquantin
d'iveline on va donc parler du sport de
de son passé de ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui et d'un venir qui est très
très riche on va parler avec Yve machbuf
bonjour bonour vous êtes le le
vice-président de la la communauté
chargée de la communication des grands
projet euh Olivier kigin vous êtes
directeur général de la Fédération
française de cyclisme et on va parler
notamment avec vous ben de la plentation
de la fédération et et du Vélodrome
Olivier roche bonjour vous êtes le
directeur du du Golf National et on va
parler évidemment de la rider Cup qui
sera le grand grand événement sportif
des des années à venir et puis max
viinier vous êtes le président de
l'Entente Athlétique de Saint-Quentin en
divline bonjour alors on va comme
toujours trois parties dans cette
émission on commence si vous voulez bien
par le le passé des premières
années les premières années alors je
vais parler plutôt avec vousu parce que
d'abord vousêes le plus ancien sur ce
plateau il faut bien qu'il porte
l'ancienneté non mais vous avez connu
aussi ces premières années c'est vrai
que c'est on en parlait quand on a fait
l'émission sur la culture c'est vrai que
la culture quelque chose d'omniprésent
qui qui faisait un lien entre entre les
les les habitants de de sa-quentin je
pense que le sport aussi c'est un c'est
un lien social formidable c'est un lien
social parce que cette population
cquentinoise est très jeune elle l'
toujours elle l'était elle l'est
toujours et le sport est un des éléments
que que chacun souhaite pratiquer et
c'est vrai que cette dynamique sportive
a a amené je dirais le territoire à non
seulement développer des activités
autour de du sport et Max Vinier nous en
dira quelques mots tout à l'heure parce
que lui aussiancien et lui aussi c'est
un ancien du territoire mais ça servi
cette dynamique sportive à à véhiculer
l'image sur l'extérieur à à montrer
concrètement que ce territoire jeune
dynamique sportif
pouvait sortir de de de de ces
frontières pour aller faire rayonner
l'image de Saint-Quentin ça signe des
démarches al il peut tellement sortir de
cette frontière qui a une initiative qui
est une des premières initiatives c'est
de participer au Tour de France à la
Voile on se dit qu'est-ce qu'ils font
dans ce Tour de France à la voile c'est
très étonnant mais à chaque fois que je
le dis les gens me regardent avec
beaucoup
de d'attention mais tout en étant étonné
nous avons à Saint-Quentin le plus grand
club de voile oui c'est ça oui et oui la
base de loisir de saintqutin qui est au
cœur de de territoire a été le le fer de
lance sur cette dynamique je dirais
sportive et et l'aventure du Tour de
France elle a duré plus de 13 ans
avec des des moments étonnants puisque
les trois catégories qui sont bah la
partie amateur la partie professionnelle
et la partie universitaire ont été gagné
par 50 ans d'blin donc faut savoir aussi
moment se retirer mais cette dynamique a
permis à à nos sportifs je dirais locaux
avec un un un leader qui était Thierry
pis champion olympique en 88 qui nous a
je dirais coaché dans T dans tous les
secteurs que ce soit le monde de
professionnel amateur ouou universitaire
et et a permis cette dynamique qui a
rayonné tout autour de la France pendant
près de 13 ans ce qui fait que
Saint-Quentin était présent sur les
côtes françaises pendant tout le mois de
juillet pendant tout le MO de juillet ça
ça a été une volonté quoi de de la
communauté d'agglomération ça ét une
volonté de la comunagglomération qui est
partie de guillancour le premier tour de
France s'est fait à guillancour et
rapidement l'ensemble des partenaires et
de la gllo se sont rendus compte que il
fallait
euh utiliser cette image du Tour de
France en fin de compte c'était on
disait il y a une assation qui s'est
créée qui s'appelait les 7 de
Saint-Quentin qui avait comme objectif
un peu de porter le projet sportif et
les 7 de Saint-Quentin ça correspondait
à nos sept communes et donc ensemble je
dirais en en profitant de cette
dynamique on a essayé d'emmener
l'ensemble de ce territoire dans dans
dans ce projet sportif avec d'ailleurs
un travail pédagogique qui s'est fait
aussi avec le monde scolaire et qui
développé après dans d'autres projets
j'en dis pas plus pour l'instant alors
il y a aussi une autre manifestation
alors qui qui existe toujours c'est je
sais pas pourquoi elle s'appelle Paris
Brest Paris ça devrait s'appeler
Saint-Quentin bre SaintQuentin mais ça
aussi ça été ça a été dès les années
c'est quand 91 je crois ça fait 20 ans
que que Saint-Quentin reçoit le le Paris
Brest Paris faut savoir que c'est une
manifestation extrêmement ancienne
puisque elle est de
1891 ça veut dire qu'elle a plus de d'un
siècle oui et euh cette manifestation
qui a été
euh professionnelle mais qui est devenue
rapidement amateur et
cyclotouriste après la dernière guerre
est devenue une manifestation dire que
c'est le bâton de maréchal du
cyclotourisme mondial puisque
aujourd'hui euh c'est presque 6000
participants euh plus de la moitié
d'étrangers euh 55 nationalités c'est un
enjeu formidable al ça pourquoi c'est
arrivrive à Saint-Quentin parce que
pareil con circonstances club
psychotourisme important sur le
territoire dynamique sportive ben les
intérêts se croisent un monde économique
qui était aussi attiré par cette image
du du sport un peu je dirais projet
individuel et qui s sans un challenge je
dirais de de de concours mais plus un
challenge personnel donc une dynamique
qui faisait que le le Paris Brest s
retrouve à Saint-Quentin mais dans une
façon parfaite et aujourd'hui ça fait 20
ans que ce Paris BR c'était la 20e année
d'Anne dernière que ce Paris BR avait
lieu avec une réussite une fête une une
ambiance extraordinaire extraordinaire
en plus ça aussi un intérêt économique
je veux dire l'ensemble des hôtels sont
bien rempli pendant cette période là
mais ça a aussi un sens pour les
cquantinois puisque il les accueillent
ces randonneurs qui viennent du qure
coin du monde chez eux d'ailleurs ça
nous entraîne pour une future
manifestation qui s'appelleent la Raider
Cup oui dont on parlera tout à l'heure
jeis peut-être un mot Bier parce que ça
c'est des gros événements mais
évidemment il y a les clubs sportifs qui
sont très importants parce que ça fait
vivre là concrètement enfin les les les
les on pas seulement des spectateurs ou
oui tout à fait parce que bon on est
sollicité alors sur le parisbrest Paris
pas forcément en tant que qu'entité
athlétique mais bon je pense que les
gens qui sont bénévoles sont souvent
sollicités pour ce genre de
manifestation puisque quand on accueille
6000 personnes avec un nombre d'étranger
comme le disait y très important il est
évident queon a besoin du tissu
associatif local pour pour encadrer et
pour organiser je sais que moi bon je
suis Guan courtois donc je sais que rien
qu' gu en cours je crois qu'on a un peu
plus de 10000 personnes qui sont
licenciées dans des associations donc il
y a un tiers voir peutê être un peu plus
du tiers des des des habitants de
guillancourt qui pratiquent dans une
association et à l'échelle de la ville
nouvelle je pense que le pourcentage est
le même donc c'est c'est vraiment très
très important ouis alors on va terminer
ce chapitre consacré à l'histoire par
bah l'implantation de Prost Grand Prix
Prost Grand Prix c'estta une aventure
certes qui a duré de 3 ans 2 ans et demi
mais qui a été extrêmement en
richichissante parce que d'abord il a
fallu
l'accueillir sur le territoire dans dans
des délais relativement courts il y a eu
des problèmes d'implantation à l'époque
sur le lieu qui était prévu à l'origine
et on a le territoire les élus ont réagi
très rapidement pour que pros
puisseinstalleraller cé 98 98 ouais je
sais que la décision la décision s'est
fait en en juillet et les les bâtiments
ont ouvert fin septembre oui ça été très
rir de voir un sujet sur Prost Grand
Prix baptisé le docteur par ses proches
pour sa capacité d'analyse Prost aura
connu une maladie fulgurante en tant que
responsable d'écurie la faillite
pourtant lorsqu'il reprend l'igier en
février 1997 le projet séduit d'autant
plus que Peugeot fournit un moteur
utilisé par l'écurie
1998 marque le vrai début de Prost avec
l'AP 01 première voiture vraiment
construite dans les locaux flamb en 9U
de guillancour celle-ci marquera un seul
point la saison 1999 sera plus positif
avec 9 points et une seconde place mais
2000 sera l'année de toutes les galères
pour Prost 0 points marqué et un manque
à gagner en prime de la Fédération
pourtant Prost repart en 2001 au combat
l'écurie marque alors 4 points c'est
évidemment loin des espoirs du
constructeur le déficit annoncé est de
30 millions d'euros un investisseur
aurait dû l'éponger et financer la
saison prochaine une dote visiblement
trop chère pour la
Marie c'est vrai qu'il y a beaucoup de
choses aussi sur le sport autom via
Jean-Pierre belaltooise qui est installé
al Jean-Pierre bet est là depuis très
longtemps il il a il a toute son
entreprise autour de la sécurité
a et c'est vrai que il a beaucoup
contribué aussi à l'image de 50 Anel
mais quand Prost je reviens sur Prost
Prost a été pour nous un un déclic
sur l'intérêt d'avoir en fin de compte
une
entreprise médiatiquement aussi
importante et sur l'attrait en fin de
compte de notre population mais aussi de
la population au-delà de notre
territoire même international sur des
activités de ce type là c'est important
pour la suite que c'est des réflexions
qui nous on amené après derrière à être
candidat sur d'autres thèmes et c'est
vrai que on a fait beaucoup participer
les 5 cantinois aussi à l'aventure de
Prost à travers un travail important
autour des essais à Manicourt mais aussi
au moment des Grands Prix où ce sont des
des centaines voir des milliers de Guan
courourtois qui se déplacit ensemble
pour suivre tout ça il y a même un club
qui s'est monté ici ça a été un moment
difficile ass c'est étonnant puisque au
moment où Prost fermé ses portes le
dimanche le lundi donc le Prost a ferm
on a eu deux écurie pendant une journée
Prost a fermé le lundi enfin le le
tribunal a a proclamé la fermeture le
lundi et Renault ouvrait au Technocentre
en courour ouvrait son écurie donc c'est
vrai que c'était une superbe aventure
c'est pas la même chose avec le avec
Renault puisque les ne sont pas là mais
mais concrètement ça nous a appris
beaucoup de choses ce sport de très haut
niveau très médiatique vraiment très
médiatique ce qui nous a permis un peu
de d'acquérir un certain nombre de de
regard et de compétences pour aller plus
loin alors Olivier roche la la
Fédération Française de Golf s'est
installée à à Saint-Quentin en quelle
année euh les constructions enfin les
premiers travaux ont été imaginés en 85
on a commencé en 88 les travaux et on
ouvrait en 90 en octobre 90
l'inauguration et quel quel est la
volonté c'était quoi c'était de d'être à
côté du centre qui allait devenir le
Golf National la la la la première
volonté du comité directeur de la
fédération à l'époque c'était de
péréniser l'organisation de son open on
avait beaucoup de difficultés d' à aller
sur de club en clubné ça évoluait ça
changeait et on souhaitait avoir nos
infrastructures et après c'est vrai que
euh par rapport au lien très fort
qu'tisse avec le ministère des sport il
nous encourageait à avoir un site mais à
l'instar de marcoussi de de cler
fontaine ou de du du tennis avec Roland
Garos d'avoir notre site de référence et
notre centre national d'entraînement
donc CIT une logique en fait pour la
fédération de trouver un site pour
construire son golf et l'organiser pour
l'OP de France recevoir pour l'OP de
France ce qui a étéit difficile trouvver
un site qui permet de tout recevoir mais
très sincèrement il y a eu qu'un seul
site de référence qui était qui a tout
de suite été Saint-Quentin où là il y
avait une volonté tant politique de
toutes les communes du préfet donc on
s'est vite retrouvé je sais que ça s'est
en fait ça s'est embrillé très
rapidement entre le moment où on a
imaginé le projet et où ça a été signé
c'était très très rapide parce qu'il y
avait une volonté tant des communes mais
aussi ça a changé parce que avant il me
semble que c'était venu Victor Hugo à
Paris je crois la Fédération la
fédération é effectivement Victor HUG
donc mais le siège est resté malgré tout
très longtemps à Victor HUG parce que on
a déménagé qu'en 98 à Le Valois mais la
Fédération le siège de la fédération est
toujours à leevois donc on a un site
dédié avec beaucoup plus de de personnes
et du personnel qui est beaucoup plus
impliqué comme la DTN au golf national
mais je dirais le siège reste encore à
aujourd'hui à leevois per alors on va
revenir dans dans quelques instants
puisquon va parler de la rider Cup mais
Max
Vigier cette entente athlétique qui a
été créé je crois à peu près hein 99 99
hein VO juste avant de
basculer vou marquer donc fait
attention là aussi ça a tiré un nombre
de Ch c'est incroyable bah l'entant
d'athlétique évidemment on parle en
terme de taille on est plus du tout dans
le même phénomène mais disons que
localement on a été un petit peu les
pionniers de de l'intercommunalité du
sport on sait que politiquement c'est
pas toujours simple au niveau sportif je
peux vous dire c'est encore moins simple
finalement donc nous on a essayé je
crois qu'au début certains nous ont
regardé un petit peu en disant ils sont
bien gentils mais ils vont faire comme
tout le monde ça va durer 2 3 ans et
puis chacun va reprendre son petit
chemin à lui et ça ça va exploser bon ça
fait c'est la 13e saison quand même
ouais euh là on regarde vers l'ondre on
espère que les couleurs de 51 seront
représenté elles étaient représenté à
Pékin à handis sport avec nantelin gaita
et avec brispanel là on espère qu'elles
seront encore représenté par ces deuxlà
plus peut-être une troisème ah c'est
bien mais bon là on est au niveau
olympique donc forcément ça va être très
très compliqué voilà non pas vraiment ah
si c'était que nous ça sera déjà fait il
déjà mais après c'est une belle aventure
mais je dirais que elle nous a presque
un petit peu dépassé d'ailleurs parce
que un moment donné euh bah une
structure vivier quoi c'est un beau
vivier avec beaucoup de bénévoles qui
ont pour certains notamment
l'encadrement technique qui on qui ont
vraiment beaucoup de compétences mais
bon c'est toutes les limites de alors
pas du sport amateur du surtout du
bénévola et d'une structure qui aurait
besoin maintenant pour passer un palier
supérieur et ne serait-ce que pour
maintenir un petit peu ce qui se fait
actuellement on est à peu près entre 750
et 800 licenciés donc des
loisiret sport de ha niveau et surtout
pour le sport de ha niveau c'est vrai
que la structure de l'association
aujourd'hui n'est plus tout à fait
adapté au besoins qu'on aurait pour
c'est devenu c'est devenu un petit peu
lourd pour les dirigeants et pour les
entraîur et puis c'est surtout qu'on a
pas le budget qui qu'on aurait besoin et
les installations malheureusement là
j'ai un él en face de moi mais sa je
déjà voilà non mais c'est un petit peu
si vous voulez bon toute comparaison
étant étant
évidemment c'est pas le vélodrome qu'on
attend depuis des années mais c'est vrai
que à titre à titre athlétique on n pas
un stade de compétition digne de ce nom
aujourd'hui malheureusement en ville
nouvelle ça n'existe enfin ça pourrait
exister mais bon on va pas rentrer dans
les détails il existe mais il fait plus
partie de la ville nouvelle donc c'est
voilà donc le passé à ce niveau làà pour
nous est pas quelque chose qui qui dans
dans un avenir proche malheureusement
pourrait faire ressurgir des des
constructions sympathique ou des des des
livraisons d'équipement sur mon repas
c'est vrai qu'on a un très beau parc des
sports avec un superbe stade
d'athlétisme mais mais qui
malheureusement est inutilisé inutilisé
euh Olivier kginer on va reparler
évidemment après de de de la fédération
de cyclisme et du Vélodrome mais est-ce
que voilà cet environnement sportif
c'est un des éléments qui vous a décidé
à à venir vous installer ici alors le
trait d'union nous c'est vraiment
l'olympisme puisque c'est vraiment le le
projet de Paris 2012 ou qui qui amènera
la Fédération dans 2 ans décembre 2013
sur sur Saint-Quentin et donc le trait
d'union il se fait à travers le tissu
associatif aussi puisque la fédération
est un et la le rassemblement des des
clubs donc d'association euh mais le le
trait d'union pour nous il est on en
parlera je pense c'est vraiment le les
jeux mais pas que puisque c'est aussi le
sport le sport au quotidien c'est
vraiment devenir s'implanter dans la
vallée de Chevreuse qui est vraiment un
terroir pour terroir des cyclistes des
cyclistes donc alors on va parler de
l'avenir dans quelques instants et dans
dans cet avenir il y a évidemment la la
rider Cup la France était candidate
elle a a remporté ça été une énorme
victoire quand est-ce que c'était la
décision 17 mai l'année dernière souvz
c'est une B pourous souvendrez sansout
toute votre vie que vous le 17
mai vers midi vous étiez avec nous
j'étais avec vous absolument on va on va
justement revoir un sujet sur
l'attribution de la Raider Cup au Golf
National de
Saint-Quentin la France organisera sur
son sol laider Cup de golf en 2018 une
première depuis la naissance de la
compétition en 1927 qui oppose tous les
2 ans une équipe européenne et une
équipe américaine c'est sur le Golf
National de Saint-Quentin en Yveline que
se déroulera ce tournoi mythique ce midi
une cinquantaine de personnes s'étaient
rassemblé à Guy en cours pour suivre en
direct à la télévision et sur les
téléphones portables cette victoire
française des jeunes joueus de l'équipe
de France qui fréquentent le parcours de
l'Albatros mais aussi le directeur du
Golf National de Saint-Quentin Olivier
roche pour nous golfeurs recevoir cet
événement mondial c'est le 3e va y avoir
une un impact colossal pour le golf
national pour la ville pour la région
pour tout le monde c'est euh et puis
pour la Fédération Française de Golf
c'est 3 ans de travail euh c'est quelque
chose enfin c'est un investissement
vraiment important et on en reçoit voilà
on récolte immédiatement euh cette rider
Cup en 2018 c'est c'est inespéré c'est
génial c'est fantastique euh c'est
vraiment un événement incroyable pour la
France pour le golf national et pour
nous qui sommes jeunes et même pour les
jeunes golfeurs qui vont avoir comme but
maintenant de jouer en France pour la
rider Cup donc je suis vraiment très
très contente et je serai là pour y
assister ce sera vraiment génial on
avait beaucoup de concurrence avec les
autres pays et donc je trouve ça
vraiment bah formidable que ce soit ici
au golf national on va pouvoir bah tous
les suivre on va pouvoir bah profiter
des installations après on va pouvoir
enfin ça va être vraiment bénéfique pour
tout le monde d'ici à 2018 entre 5 et 6
millions d'euros devrait devrait être
investi pour mettre à niveau le parcours
et les infrastructures selon le
directeur national du golf 50000
spectateurs dont une majorité
d'étrangers sont attendu sur le fairway
yvelinois la dernière édition gagnée par
les Européens l'automne dernier au pays
de Gall a touché par la télévision 620
millions de foyer dans 195 pays et les
retombées économiques ont été évaluées à
plus de 94 millions
d'euros on voit bien que il buuf ou
Olivier roche ENF l'enjeu est évidemment
sportif mais il dépasse de beaucoup le
sport enfin c'est aussi un enjeu
économique formidable je crois que
toutes les manifestations après de ce
niveau-là que ce soit d'ailleurs vers le
véodrome la RER Cup même le parisvest
Paris ont au-delà de l'engouement
sportif qui correspond bien aux
habitants du territoire il y a aussi
tout l'aspect économique qui est alors
plus on monte je dirais plus les les les
les éléments de les retours les
retombées pour le territoire sont sont
importants et et et aujourd'hui
indispensable dans vous avez eu il y a
des je dirais dans les discussions sur
l'économie il est évident que si on veut
attirer des entreprises il faut montrer
aussi qu'on a un territoire dynamique et
aujourd'hui la rider Cup est
certainement dans l'ensemble de de tous
mes projets celle qui va être avec des
conséquences économiques les les plus
importants mais j'attends avec
impatience l'ouverture du Vélodrome
parce que alors pouron du Vélodrome
alors la fédération de cyclisme c'est
2013 hein le Vélodrome c'est 2013 c'est
la même date c'est le contra
actuellement c'est 14 décembre
2013 et on attend avec impatience nous
le le déménagement puisque on est
actuellement sur Renis sousbois h donc
on est dans les bureaux administratif
assez classique et demain on sera dans
un univers de sport au quotidien ce qui
change quand même aussi la manière de
travailler les partenaires que vous
pouvez avoir péréniser ou les nouveaux
c'est c'est un bel outil attractif en
tout cas al il va servir à quoi ce
vélodrome il va servir mais enfon alors
il va servir au fond sport de de haut
niveau de très haut niveau puisque le
vélodrome comme comme vous dites c'est
c'est le Centre national du cyclisme
donc c'est un Vélodrome pour faire de la
piste mais c'est aussi un stadium de BMX
qui est un un nouveau une nouvelle
discipline olympique depuis 2008 tous
les vélos si je peux dire et on aura
également un circuit routier autour du
du plan d'eau de 15 km donc faire faire
du vélo sur route en région
Île-de-France sur 15 km en site propre
c'est quand même assez unique et la
colline des lancours sera également euh
équipée pour le VTT hm hm donc le siège
de la fédération sera à ce moment-là à
Saint-Quentin avec ces sportifs d'élite
et quand je vous disait pas que parce
que on on souhaite également avoir le
comité régional d'Île-de-France de
cyclisme à nos côtés avec ses athlètes
donc le sport régional et on
souhaiterait en concertation avec la la
communauté d'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin que ça soit également
ouvert au grand public et que on a des
des jeunes qui viennent s'initier des
jeunes et des moins jeunes qui viennent
s'initier donc à la piste mais aussi au
BMI d'accord donc c'est un projet grand
public c'est c'est pas quelque chose
d'indfférent même pour vous enfin
l'arrivée du Vélodrome ah non mais c'est
c'est enfin c'est une excellente chose
voilà exactement et puis enfin le
vélodrome le projet du Vélodrome était
quand même très très axé Jeux Olympiques
2012 on sait que Paris ou la France sera
encore candidat à des jeux olympiques
dans quelques années le golf maintenant
on l'espère tout du moins exactement
mais le Golf vient de rentrer Jeux
Olympiques également donc si dans la
commune j'irais ou plutôt dans la la
ville nouvelle Saint-Quentin on a deux
sites de référence Olympiques qui sont
donc le vélo et le golf c'est vrai que
ça donne une dimension internationale
enfin même mondiale pour tant la rider
Cup c'est une chose mais sur les Jeux
Olympiques c'est c'est un vrai enjeu
c'est c'est non non c'est bien d'ici
2018 vous pensez qu'il y aura un
Français qui pourra participer à la
rider Cup et on a déjà eu deux Français
qu' voilà il y a déjà eu ça il est
peut-être plus dur pour les Français de
de d'être dans les équipes de rider Cup
dans le sens où euh par rapport au
nombre de de de sportifs de haut niveau
bah il y a voilà de pratiquants quand on
a 10 millions de golfeur sur les au
Royaume-Uni et seulement 400000 en
France le le le décalage important même
au niveau se fait donc sur les circuits
mondiaux s'il y a 200 anglais on va y
avoir que 20 français donc forcément
plus on monte plus l'entend noir se
rétrécit et naturellement il y a plus
d'anglais que de français maintenant la
Fédération travaille euh et on commence
à vraiment à avoir des résultats dans
tous les domaines et je pense que on
serait capable de l'avoir mais on l'a
fait et le sport le sportif de haut
niveau c'est pas que la Fédération c'est
c'est justement cette cette difficulté
de suivre le sportif de niveau dans sa
volonté dans ses envies n'oublion pas
non plus querique pas un champion ça se
fabrique pas ça se découvre ça
s'entretient et après bah quand il
devient professionnel il y a des sports
qui restent professionnels avec les
fédérations c'est peut-être le cas du
cyclisme au niveau du golf ça s'arrête
c'estàdire que la Fédération c'est
peut-être pas son travail où ça l'était
pas de travailler sur le professionnel
donc maintenant ça le devient mais il
est beaucoup plus difficile nous de
suivre des sportifs qui deviennent
professionnels qui y aussi beaucoup
d'argent et de les forcer à continuer à
faire du haut niveau c'est pas c'est pas
si simple que ça avec l'arrivée des Jeux
Olympiques pour le golf je pense qu'on
va avoir beaucoup plus cette cette
thématique en place et les jeunes qui
vont arriver sont beaucoup plus voilà
sont beaucoup plus sur ce registre et
évidemment une des ambitions de la la
commission stratégique de haut niveau de
la Fédération c'est d'avoir dès 2016 au
moins un champion et espérz en avoir
deux en 2018 évidemment Yv MAF en
conclusion de de cette émission sur sur
le sport on a l'impression que le sport
à 5anta voilà c'est d'abord un besoin
pour les habitants c'est mais c'est
aussi une fierté non c'est une fierté
parce que lorsque vous êtes avant tout
sportif max VI disait tout à l'heure on
a plus de 50 % de la population qui est
déjà dans une dynamique sportive donc
quand vous êtes même si c'est pas votre
sport qui est entre guillemets dans
l'élite puisque tous les sports tout
sont pas dans l'élite à sa-quentin
quelquesuns il y a une fierté de
territoire de de de montrer qu'on qu'on
vit dans une dynamique sportive et
aujourd'hui chaque fois que vous
rencontrez quelqu'un qui qui vous dit
oui moi je fais tel sport le football
est aussi une activité extrêmement
développée sur le le teritire 5 le rugby
je veux dire néanmoins la fierté d'avoir
et je dirais le Vélodrome avec tout ce
qui va y avoir entre le BMX la piste
mais aussi un peu de route mais aussi le
le cyclourisme le golf il y a une fierté
d'être d'être cinquantinois et et de
faire partie en fin de compte de ce
territoire qui est dans une dynamique
qui va ailleurs s'amplifier parce
qu'aujourd'hui on est en dans les dans
dans les prémist je veux dire on sait
qu'aujourd'hui on a l'Open de France sur
ce territoire l' Open de demain et
d'après-demain va va prendre de
l'amplitude parce qu'il y a la Rader Cup
et donc l'intérêt aujourd'hui des des
médias mais l'intérêt aussi des sportifs
va se dimuper le jour on aura les
championnats du monde et on les aura
Monsieur le Directeur c'est
déjàà en négociation he sur SaintQuentin
les 5 qutinois seront fier d'abord je
d'aller voir d'All voir pu que c'est à
côté de sa porte et puis de pouvoir voir
rayonner leur territoire non non c'est
une fierté ça c'est sûr donc on dit
quoiigier Kiner bienvenu hein ça bah
c'est plus que bienvenu même la
Fédération qu' déjà depuis longtemps
pour la Fédération moi je suis en plus
Manois en plus j'habite déjà j'ai fait
le choix de d'habiter sur déjà sur oui
c'est ça vous avez déjà déménagé hein
j'habite sur Manil àau mais le les
grands projets les championnats du monde
on a déjà eu des des entretiens avec la
Fédération internationale des les
championnats européens on a déjà eu des
entretiens avec la Fédération Européenne
et le championnat de France qui est de
la compétence de la Fédération nous en
avons déjà parlé avec les les élus de 1
et en 2014 j'espère qu'il y aura une
belle inauguration dans les deux
disciplines du VTT pardon du BMX et de
la
piste la France l'Europe et ensuite le
champion du monde que des bonnes
nouvelles il y en a pas tous les jours
heant autant les merci infiniment à tous
les cas cette émission est terminée à
bientôt pour un nouveau rendez-vous
consacré au 40 ans de Saint-Quentin en
Eveline